we have disturbing new surveillance
video from Jersey City New Jersey this
shows the moment that two attackers
opened fire on a Jewish owned grocery
store now the state's attorney general
says there is growing evidence that the
motive of these shooters was hate Don
Dahler is at the scene in Jersey City
which is just across the river from
where we are in Manhattan Don what kind
of evidence do prosecutors have well
they are looking at what's being
described as a manifesto style document
that was found here at the scene as well
as a number of weapons and that new
surveillance video that shows a
completely different angle of the attack
they believe that David Andersen was
wielding an ar-15 you can see him firing
on the street before he enters the store
with the other suspect Francine Graham
right behind him with a shotgun
investigators say the shooters also had
handguns one of them with a homemade
silencer and a device to catch shell
casings in all officers say they
recovered five guns a pipe bomb and
hundreds of shell casings at the scene a
law enforcement source confirmed a
manifesto style document was also found
inside the u-haul truck that was used by
the suspects the letter was described as
a few pages and contained lists of
grievances as well as groups that were
hated the attackers killed three people
in the store and a police officer at a
cemetery about a mile away before being
killed in a gun battle with police two
of the victims Mendel Firenze and Moshe
Deutsch have been laid to rest and a
funeral will be held next week for
Jersey City police detective Joseph
seals he is a father of five the other
victim
Douglas Miguel Rodriguez will be sent
back to his home his native home in
Ecuador after a funeral on Sunday his
family tells us that he's been living in
this country for three years legally
with his wife and an 11 year old
daughter
Anthony Dunn thank you very much Don
Dahler